I WANT TO BRING IN ATTORNEY AND
CONTRIBUTING COLUMNIST AT THE
"WASHINGTON POST" GEORGE CONWAY.
GEORGE, GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS
MORNING.
PLEASE, LET'S JUST TAKE A STEP
BACK.
BECAUSE THIS IS SO UNUSUAL.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE, SO WHEN YOU HEARD
THAT THE FBI EXECUTED A SEARCH
WARRANT AT THE HOME OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, WHAT QUESTIONS
DOES TELL RAISE FOR YOU?
WHAT STANDARDS IN YOUR MIND,
MUST HAVE BEEN MET?
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY, IT HAS TO
MEET THE BASIC STANDARD OF ANY
SEARCH WARRANT, YOU HAVE TO SHOW
PROBABLE CAUSE THAT A SOMEONE,
MIGHT NOT BE DONALD TRUMP OR IT
COULD BE DONALD TRUMP COMMITTED
A CRIME AND PROBABLE CAUSE THAT
THERE IS EVIDENCE OF THAT CRIME
IN THE LOCATION BEING SEARCHED.
AND YOU HAVE TO PARTICULARIZE
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR AND YOU HAVE TO PUT
THAT NULL IN AN AFFIDAVIT THAT A
FEDERAL JUDGE REVIEWS AND MAKE
THE DETERMINATION THAT THERE IS
SUFFICIENT CAUSE TO INVADE
SOMEONE'S PRIVACY AND COME INTO
SOMEONE'S HOME AND DO THIS.
THAT'S ONE THING.
AGAIN, THIS IS A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
AND THE POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES,
THE NATIONAL CONSEQUENCES, OF
GOING OVER YOUR SKIS ON THIS ARE
JUST TOO HUGE FOR ANYTHING BUT
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE, I
THINK, THAT WOULD JUSTIFY
MERRICK GARLAND.
SO HE'S CAUTIOUS, A CAUTIOUS
PERSON TO AUTHORIZE THIS.
AND IT HAD TO BE AUTHORIZED BY
HIM PERSONALLY.
SO, YOU HAVE TO ASK, WHAT IS IT
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT HAS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO THIS STEP.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY DON'T QUITE
TRUST HIM BECAUSE THEY,
OBVIOUSLY, DON'T THINK THAT
SUBPOENAING HIM AND REQUESTING
DOCUMENTS FROM HIM WILL GET THEM
THE ANSWERS THAT THEY WANT.
BUT WHAT IS IT THAT THEY WANT?
WELL, IT PROBABLY ISN'T JUST
THAT HE TOOK SOME-N DO DOCUMENTA
RUSH AND PACKED THEM IN 15 BOXES
AND SHIPPED THEM TO MAR-A-LAGO
WITHOUT FOCUSING WHAT'S IN THEM.
OKAY.
IT'S GOT TO BE SOMETHING MORE.
IT'S GOT TO BE THE NATURE OF THE
MATERIALS, OR, IT COULD BE THAT
HE SENT SOME BACK AND
REPRESENTED, JUST SPECULATING
HERE, HE'S NOT THE MOST HONEST
PERSON IN THE WORLD AND NOT THE
MOST METICULOUS IN OBEYING LAWS
AND RULES, MAYBE HE DIDN'T SEND
THEM ALL BACK.
AND THERE'S A SUSPICION THAT
MAYBE HE DIDN'T SEND THEM ALL
BACK AND IN WHICH CASE HE MIGHT
BE POSSIBLILY LIABLE FOR MAKING
FALSE STATEMENTS THROUGH HIS
LAWYERS TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE NEED TO SEE WHAT THE FBI
PRESENTED TO THIS FEDERAL JUDGE.
IT COULD BE THAT SOME DOCUMENTS
WERE DESTROYED.
IT COULD BE SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
IT COULD BE THAT MAYBE THERE'S
SOME OVERLAP BETWEEN THE
MATERIALS HE KEPT OF JANUARY
6th, THAT'S EVEN POSSIBLE.
ALTHOUGH THERE'S NO INDICATION
OF THAT.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING HERE THAT
MADE THIS QUITE, MORE THAN JUST
SOMEBODY MISTAKENLY
ACCIDENTALLY, OR CARELESSLY
PACKING 15 BOXES OF MATERIALS
AND SENDING THEM TO MAR-A-LAGO.
HIS EXCUSE IS HEY, I'M PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, I DIDN'T
FOCUS ON THIS, I WAS BUSY.
BUT WHAT HE WAS BUSY WITH IS
LAUNCHING A COUP.
>> NARRATIVE COMING FROM HIS
CAMP, COMING FROM HIS SON ERIC
IS THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES ISSUE.
WOULD THERE POTENTIALLY BE AN
INTEREST IN PUTTING THAT
NARRATIVE OUT THERE GE, GEORGE,
REALLY IT WOULD BE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT?
AND WOULD THEY NECESSARILY KNOW
IF IT WAS SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
>> THEY MAY NOT NECESSARILY
KNOW.
BECAUSE THE SEARCH WARRANT COULD
BE FOR ALL DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
UNLAWFULLY RETAINED PURSUANT, OR
VIOLATION OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT.
AND THAT COULD BE, BASICALLY,
EVERYTHING HE TOOK FROM
MAR-A-LAGO -- NOT FROM
MAR-A-LAGO, TO MAR-A-LAGO, TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THAT COULD INCLUDE JANUARY
6th MATERIAL, IT MAY NOT.
IT JUST DEPENDS ON WHAT'S THERE.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE SOME BASIS
TO CONCLUDE THERE'S SOMETHING
INTERESTING THERE.
AND THEY TOOK OUT APPARENTLY
BOXES AND BOXES OF MATERIALS
SUGGESTING THAT MAYBE HE DID NOT
RETURN ALL OF THE MATERIALS.
OR MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING IN
THERE THAT INDICATES SOME
NEFARIOUS INTENT -- HE HAD SOME
NEFARIOUS INTENT IN BRINGING THE
DOCUMENTS TO MAR-A-LAGO.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW AT THIS
POINT.
>> IF THERE WERE A CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENT OF SOME KIND THAT THE
FARMER PRESIDENT HAD IMPROPERLY
KEPT, MANIPULATED, DESTROYED,
WHATEVER, HOW AND WHY WOULD IT
BE IN THE NATIONAL INTEREST FOR
THE FBI TO GET ITS HANDS ON
THAT?
>> WELL, I MEAN, IF THERE ARE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THERE, OR
EVIDENCE OF CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE MISHANDLED, MISTREATED
OR DESTROYED, YOU KNOW, THAT'S A
VERY SERIOUS THING.
PEOPLE HAVE GONE TO JAIL FOR
THAT.
AND PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN CONVICTED
OF THAT.
AND IF HE DID IT WITH A LARGE
NUMBER OF DOCUMENTS, I THINK
THERE'S BEEN SOME REPORTING THAT
EVEN THE LIST OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IS LONG, AND SOME OF
THE DOCUMENTS MAY HAVE BEEN SO
SENSITIVE THAT THEY COULDN'T
ACTUALLY DESCRIBE THE DOCUMENT
WITHOUT MAKING A LIST THAT WAS
CLASSIFIED.
THIS COULD BE VERY SERIOUS
MATERIALS WITH SERIOUS NATIONAL
SECURITY INTERESTS IN JEOPARDY,
BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP'S
CARELESSNESS.
OR, WORSE.
>> WHY SHOULD THIS BE VIEWED, OR
SHOULD IT NOT BE VIEWED, AS
THESE DOJ PROBES ENCIRCLING, OR
GETTING TIGHTER, AROUND DONALD
TRUMP?
>> WELL, IT ABSOLUTELY IT.
I MEANER, THE FACT -- THEY HAVE
CROSSED -- I HATE TO USE THE
METAPHOR BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
USING IT -- THEY HAVE CROSSED
THE RUBICON HERE.
IT'S UNPRECEDENTEDED  ED ED FOR.
EVEN SAN CLEMENTE, RICHARD
THINGS'S HOUSE AT SAN CLEMENTE.
IT'S JUST REMARKABLE THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD TAKE
SUCH A STEP.
AND THE FACT THAT A FEDERAL
JUDGE APPROVED, HEY, THEY'VE GOT
SOMETHING THERE.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> THIS IS NOT VERY MERRICK
GARLAND --
>> WELL, HE IS MERRICK GARLAND
IN THE FOLLOWING SENSE, HE TRULY
BELIEVES AS HE HAS SAID
REPEATEDLY THAT NO ONE IS ABOVE
THE LAW.
SO, THIS HAS BEEN AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT.
BUT IT'S ALSO NOT NECESSARILY
MERRICK GARLAND IN JUST THE FACT
THAT IT'S NO MATTER WHAT THE
PREDICATE IS, IT'S A BOLD STEP.
SO, YOU KNOW, HE'S NOT SOMEONE
WHO DOES THINGS RATIONALLY.
SO YOU HAVE TO TEND TO CONCLUDE
THERE IS SOMETHING THERE BEHIND
THE CURTAIN THAT WOULD SURPRISE
US OR SHOCK US OR SOMETHING.
>> HOW SERIOUSLY SHOULD DONALD
TRUMP BE TAKING THIS, DO YOU
THINK, GEORGE?
>> I -- I THINK ANYTIME THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION
COMES TO YOUR HOUSE EARLY IN THE
MORNING AND KNOCKS ON THE DOOR
AND STARTS RUMMAGING THROUGH
YOUR HOME WITH A LIST OF THINGS
THAT IT'S SPECIFICALLY LOOKING
FOR, YOU SHOULD BE WORRIED.
>> YOU HAVE HEARD NO DOUBT --
>> I'D BE WORRIED IF I WAS HIM.
>> LOOK, WE KEEP SAYING THAT
DONALD TRUMP CONFIRMED THE
EXECUTION OF THIS WARRANT.
HE DIDN'T CONFIRM IT, HE
ANNOUNCED.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE ONE WHO GOT
OUT IN FRONT OF THIS AND SAID,
HEY, THE FBI HAS BEEN OUT THERE
SEARCHING.
SO, IN A WAY, HE HAS TRIED TO
CONTROL THIS STORY FROM
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON AND INTO
EVENING.
PART OF THAT, WE HAVE SEEN TRUMP
ALLIES AND A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
SAYING, HEY, WAIT A SECOND, THIS
IS A WIN-SHUT.
WE'VE HEARD CRIES TO DEFUND THE
FBI.
PEOPLE SAYING THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS IN THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING U.S.
REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT,
GEORGE?
>> I MEAN, IT'S ACTUALLY
DISGRACEFUL.
THESE ARE PEOPLE SAYING DEFUND
THE POLICE WHEN THE LAWS ARE
BEING APPLIED TO PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HOLD POLITICAL POWER AND
DON'T HAVE BILLION OF POWER.
AND YET NOW, THEY WANT TO DEFUND
THE FBI ON ABSOLUTELY NO BASIS
AT ALL BECAUSE THEY DON'T
EXACTLY KNOW WHAT THE FACTS ARE.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE FACTS
ARE.
IT'S JUST THAT THEIR FEARLESS
LEADER, HIS CONDUCT HAS BEEN
CALLED INTO QUESTION.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE EVER REASON
TO DISTRUST DONALD TRUMP, WE
HAVE EVERY REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT HE IS A PATHOLOGICAL LIAR,
SOMEONE WHO BENDS THE TRUTH,
DISTORTS THE TRUTH, YOU KNOW,
THEY ARE BASICALLY SAYING THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ENGAGING IN
SOME KIND OF A POLITICAL ATTACK.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
THERE'S NO REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT.
AND THERE'S NO BASIS FOR THEM TO
ASSERT THAT.
>> THEY'RE ALSO SAYING, DONALD
TRUMP SUPPORTERS, LOOK AT HOW
HILLARY CLINTON WAS TREATED,
RIGHT?
AND LOOK HOW DONALD TRUMP WAS
TREATED, MAKING THIS APPLES TO
APPLES CASE AS THEY SEE IT.
AND THEY'RE SAYING THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS BEING TREATED
DIFFERENTLY.
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> I THINK HILLARY CLINTON WOULD
BEG TO DIFFER.
I MEAN, SHE WENT THROUGH A VERY
LENGTHY INVESTIGATION OF YEAR,
YEAR AND A HALF.
AND SHE TESTIFIED ON THIS --
ACTUALLY COOPERATED WITH A
LENGTHY, INTRUSIVE INVESTIGATION
OF HER CONDUCT.
ULTIMATELY, SOME PEOPLE BELIEVE,
IT COST HER THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
SO, SHE DIDN'T GET OFF EXACTLY
SCOT-FREE, THAT'S ON THE ONE
HAND.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE ARE THIS IS GOING TO LEAD.
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HEAD
OF IS.
THIS COULD LEAD TO A CONVICTION
OF SORTS OR IT MIGHT -- WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT DID.
WITH DON'T NOW HOW SENSITIVE
THESE DOCUMENTS COMPARED TO THE
VARIOUS EMAILS THAT WERE ON
SECRETARY CLINTON'S PRIVATE
SERVER.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW ANY OF THAT.
AND TO PREJUDGE IT IN THAT WAY
IS INTENSITY HYPOTHETICAL,
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO WERE SAYING LOCK
HER UP.
AND SO, IF YOU WERE ACQUIRE THE
SAME STANDARDS HERE, THEY SHOULD
BE SAYING LOCK HIM UP.
>> GEORGE JCONWAY, GREAT TO HAV
YOU HERE, TELLING US WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW, OR FRANKLY WHAT WE
DON'T NEED TO KNOW OR FIND OUT.
THERE ARE SO MANY QUESTIONS OUT
THERE THANK YOU, GEORGE.